Could you provide an example of when and why would request a rifle take?
So the same reason why you request a cheek swab.
So you could just check that on the cheek swab form.
It's a check box.
Just, you know, some people just want to, hey, I just want to reach it.
You know, I just doing this as a recheck like you'd go to the doctor for a recheck.
Or some people will check because of symptoms.
So maybe you're having an increase amount of symptoms.
That's why you want another cheek swab test.
And that might be why you want me to check for a right testing to.
If we want to add any other frequencies.
Now, usually, honestly, I test for.
I make the decision whether I'm going to change your program.
If you ask for it or not.
But, but the biggest reason why somebody would want a right update is if they're not doing well.
Or maybe even more common reason is that they're doing really well.
And they, you know, they're spouse, you know, sleeps in the same bed with them and.
Hey, can you, you know, I'm doing really great with my husband has prostate issues.
Some prostate programs in my overnight.
So he can, you know, doesn't have to do it for either day.
That's another one reason why people ask for it.